Alex spake is Professor David Clarke David is a professor of law at Flinders University
and has published papers on Magna Carta since the two thousand.
He recently wrote a book for a book published by the very comparison
and will present a piper to special senate seminar on the charter Tiber this work is part of a long term interest in
key constitutional highlights.
In particular he writes about the way in which inherited constitutional rights months have been transformed by the
modern low and his. Topic today is Magna Carta in a strike.
I think straight twenty fifteen the power of a myth and an idea place welcome to him. Thanks.
Or I will thank you very much. I'd like to thank the history Council for inviting me.
On something of a tour to rezone and will cover grounds and some interior dealt with by colleagues earlier.
But I thought it might be useful to start.
By looking at the proposition I wish to advance which is the main the card has survived by being changed.
If it merely been simply a static medieval document we wouldn't be talking about very much.
Today in a country which remember. Was not known to Europe in thirty in the thirteenth century.
So the question of course is how is it that we've come to look at this document this way.
Well the answer quickly and I should say to demonstrate that this is true transformation.
And it was a transformative doctrine why from the beginning as we've heard from Nicholas in particular in the
thirteenth century there were essentially.
A number of agreements struck as we know it didn't survive very long a benign weeks initially
and then of course it was reissued. Twice as we've heard. And one I want to mention because no one has so far.
At the end of the twelve sixteen there was a special Magna Carta for Holland.
And it's available by the way on Irish websites. So I was adapting the English document.
So I ran for instead of referring to the English Church being free said the Irish Church will be free.
Instead of referring to the liberties of London referred to the liberties of Dublin.
Said referring to English rivers that refer to the River Liffey and of course it listed the Irish barons
and by the way that document still part of Irish law.
It we've heard it became a statute in twelve twenty five and twelve ninety seven
and this is why it's actually quite important because they stepped three versions have remained part of the law in
England and in the States
and it's with looking at that the English of course while they're celebrating the Magna Carta this year is an enormous
exercise in tourism in the U.K.
Right now with that sentimental about Magna Carta because in one thousand sixty three onwards they repealed most of the
terms of a twelve ninety seven statute and three substantive changes chapters
and they're actually called chapters not because the original document as you know it was
and we've seen an example over here was in continuous Latin prose with no subdivisions
but in the eighteenth century William Blackstone the great English lawyer produced a critical edition
and he introduced the idea of divisions into chapters and that spin the convention in a sense.
So the three that remain as part of English or is the proposition English law of English Church will be free
and we've heard from Nicholas what the context was it has nothing to do with freedom of religion.
They had the idea that the appointment of a possible figures in the English Church would be in the hands of the church
and not in the hands of the king the other one that remains the liberties of London. Obviously not everybody.
Things applied to a stranger on the other hand the one that one talks about
and I thought you might like to see the text is Chapter twenty on it's quite an elaborate set of sentences it combines
two of the chapters from twelve fifteen name is chapters thirty nine and forty inside here modifies the language.
So the word delay in Chapter forty.
After twelve fifteen doesn't actually appear in twelve to twelve ninety seven edition.
But everyone agrees that the notion of delay is implicit in this language will say in a moment.
It refers to things which we no longer have in the law
and generally these Take the phrase by lawful judgment of his peers sometimes wrongly thought to mean jury trial.
Jury isn't mentioned in the document that we've heard that juries of a form existed at the time
but the language of course continued to be used for many centuries why.
Well there are various ways in which is transmitted down to it's not just as a statute.
Up to fourteen eighty five there were periodic complaints about breaches of Magna Carta
and the Kings sure Jews during the St centuries would simply issue commissions of inquiry.
To see if breaches actually occurred. These in the various parliamentary roles and documents.
It's been reaffirmed numerous times in English acts of parliament
and is often if you look at the old statute books common in every state choose simply to reaffirm the charter
and then go on to make. The latest legislation. Quiet during the times are actually the lawyers are interested in it.
There's a practice of legal education whereby readings meaning elections were given by senior barristers at the ends of
court. And a reading essentially was an exposition and analysis of an act meant. And there.
Quite a few readings on Magna Carta right through this period
and in fact the Selden society which publishes publish legal material in England is producing a special volume this
year on these readings to do with making a counter.
But the great change occurred in the seventeenth century because the great Jacobean lawyer and parliamentarian
and he was a suite of the House of Commons at one stage as well said would cook it is pronounced coke.
We know that because the spelling was different in their time
and we also know that the part of Norfolk from which he came in was pronounced coke
when one said to tell students this.
It's got nothing to do with Coca-Cola he published a series of famous lawbook which was from Italy boring.
But used for many centuries called the Institute of the laws of England.
And his second Institute starts off with a long chapter on Magna Carta.
And he explains that it was the route to which all liberties in England grew.
And so what we have here is a transformation from medieval liberties
and grievances most of which are even by his time passed into history into the notion of
and we've heard earlier from John. And his speech of the liberties of the free born Englishman.
Which is a phrase used in political argument and discourse both by lawyers and non lawyers in the seventeenth century.
And.
We come to Australia three of the states actually have including New South Wales Imperial acts application legislation
which essentially lists for their jurisdiction the various constitutional legislation from England which is part of the
jurisdiction and all of these three wells that are in Queensland.
Up to twenty nine is still part of the formal law of the jurisdiction. The other three states didn't do that.
It's been recommended so their case Magna Carta came along with all other English statutes on civil mint.
And they had a reception date systems as they have a strike which is where I'm from the reception date is the twenty
eighth of December eighteenth eighty six point any English and is a remember in English statute.
It's not a Scottish date chewed it was never part of Scottish law.
As a rather crabby memorandum from a Scottish Law Society pointed out to the House of Commons in two thousand
and seven.
Because I was being asked are you going to celebrate Magna Carta in the Scots said no it's an English act
and of course English Scottish lawyers from the seventeenth century on it made their point.
So
and their case of these other jurisdictions in all the states is automatically becomes part of the law of jurisdiction.
Now the problem of course with a medieval statute was this court of medieval languages.
Hey are you going to make it work in a modern context and the answer is I need my being adapted.
And there are various ways of adapting it but what I want to do deal with a number of misconceptions about it.
There are arguments and make the kinds of mentioned dozens of times in step cases in this country.
There is a superior constitutional instrument against which to measure the villainy or all other straight
and they just Station. This is wrong.
The high court slate that idea in a case involving a Chinese person in one thousand nine hundred five
when that sort of argument was raised and it keeps being raised again.
I'll give you one quick musing story nine hundred eighty six and that
but can't in where else Queensland try to disqualify his rivals in a parliamentary election by sea.
I think that maybe the Canada only authorized currency in the form of coins since his opponents had all paid
parliamentary deposits of checks or Visa cards it's a trap. They should be disqualified.
And he of course will get a free run now. Justice.
Wilson who heard this case it was an application not the full bench
and the High Court threw it out by pointing out that maybe the counter like any other inherited state you can be
modified
and changed by valid Australian IT JUST lation And obviously that would include valid Australian education on currency.
He didn't deal with the obvious other practical point that if this man had been for rate.
How do you pay for a six hundred thousand dollars.
Hells with a truckload of two dollar coins because the logic of his argument is that there's been no movement in
financial arrangements since the thirteenth century
and clearly you couldn't run a modern economic system just by tossing coins around.
It may be modified by an Australian Parliament and may actually be superseded by later legislation
but there are several missed the greatest myth because it's just the systems and currency is that was signed.
I regret to say that when I first got the advertisement for this. Session.
I was told in the advertising it was something about signing the making the car.
I hope that's been erased the king probably couldn't write.
That's what his body biography suggest
but as we know from the four surviving call of copies three have seals attached one doesn't
but it does have a hole in the vellum. Where the code would have gone.
And that was established by an English historical caller in. One hundred twenty four.
And there are of course in the strains of understood this.
So in these famous debates in the sixty's in the Commonwealth Parliament I think it was God's will
and he noticed that the counter had been of course speed. Sealed not signed.
Now I mention that because last year I write a very crappy piece online called a confederacy of dunces
and was a bear an examination of the high school textbooks in this history textbooks in Australia which cover Magna
Carta and almost all of them saying there was a lot of signing going on. I had to say that it's totally false.
It tells us something about the writers perhaps.
So although I agree we should be trying to fuse knowledge of the rule of law and constitutional inheritance.
It is rather important to be accurate. And not fanciful.
Secondly tells Arjun jury trials were heard the juries of the time didn't exist in the form we have now
and then we actually in the later in any case there were jury isn't mentioned it does say a jury of one's peers
but at the time and later they came to mean a special jury for the arest credits
or peers who had to be judged by other peers and that was a principle that remained in English law until removal
and nine hundred forty eight. The last trial like that incredibly was nine hundred thirty three.
That was a script which they were I would point to make an account or a source as an origin behaviors corpus.
I've written to monographs about this. I sort of know about it.
But it's my advertising that very simply made corpus as a turn predated making account of their references
and twelve hundred six and twelve fourteen. So could have been created by Magna Carta.
And in the form in which we use corpus and they used to be six forms of the writ.
Don't really comes into its own in the sixteen. Seventies and Eighties. So maybe the Carter didn't create that either.
As an origin of human rights.
Well the term human rights interestingly enough an interesting which language in the sixteenth twenties.
Was widely used in nineteenth century.
Strayer
and thanks to the fabulous National Library digitalisation program you can look at all the national newspapers free of
charge
and I invite you to do so if you've never done it you just write intro into Google it takes you to the National Library
site. And the digital newspaper collection. It's a source now for historical works.
And so the phrase human rights appears in Sydney newspaper in one thousand nine hundred nineteen.
But it didn't exist then as we know
and I think there's some discussion one of the questions about this human rights are generally thought to be universal
and character ought to be and the right course in the way it was in the basis of parliamentary democracy either.
As Robert Menzies pointed out in the speech to which Rosemary made reference earlier he actually said the Barents
when sending out a democracy or anything like it. And it's not the foundation of the rule of law or either.
It doesn't mean we don't have the rule of law and it doesn't mean that made the car or isn't important
but think about the word foundation it's a building term.
So I want to build a builds a building they lay the foundations.
They know they are cold foundations because I go on to complete the rest of the building the Baron's didn't say in the
meadow at Runnymede let's create the foundations for a legal system in a country we don't know exists
and for ideas that haven't yet come into existence some hundreds of years in the future they did of course hope it was
a very medieval idea that Magna Carta would be perpetual and last forever. Of course we know for a few weeks.
So one of the things I didn't know about but which have subsequently emerged often the name of Magna Carta
but didn't exist in the thirteenth century Well federalism. Judicial independence.
Knickers mentioned the references to judges and there was a vision of a judge.
Do you just believe in eighty's and there's a. Medieval scholarship.
On that judicial independence as a legal concept didn't emerge in the English model seven hundred with the Act of
Settlement and we didn't actually start operating until seventeen fourteen and wasn't the doctrine in Australia
when Australian courts were set up because judges have offices. Pleasure..
They didn't have independence there and he came in and the eight hundred fifty S. Separation of powers.
Well this is an idea emerges in the eighteenth century and I we're going to sociate it's with.
The French right I'm on to skeer.
And his book The Spirit of laws in seven hundred forty eight but actually he got the idea
and conversation with English writers after a trip to England in Sydney in twenty eight.
And of course there's no separation of powers in a medieval kingdom simply because in part.
There wasn't a proper parliament yet so the king was and censure legislator as well as an executive.
Universal suffrage and secret ballot Well these are of phenomena of the nineteenth and twentieth centuries.
Nobody the ordinary people didn't have a vote is no there was a system of medieval elections believe it or not
but it wasn't based on universal That's the key word suffrage and of course a secret ballot.
Which Australia has a notable role in its creation and the fusion didn't exist in either.
Religious toleration Well that didn't exist because there was only one church
and heretics of course were dealt with severely. Equality before the law.
Well in a hierarchical society where there were serfs. You don't have a quality you have inequality.
Nevertheless these are things which we have course come to acquire in the course of the history
and this is the transformation of making a counter not from a medieval document
but into a series of key constitutional ideas.
And right now actually tonight Pope rained extinguish medieval historian in English law giving a lecture in Adelaide
which I will miss but he is also giving lectures elsewhere in the country
and he wrote an entry in an encyclopedia a couple of years ago
when he made that observation of this shift from particular English liberties in the thirteenth century to the idea of
the constitutional values.
So I say it's often raised by litigants really whom are terribly eccentric
and I just mentioned made a counter they refer to the Book of Genesis and have a very sour things.
Judges are amazingly patient when they hear these arguments by the way.
Sometimes it's been the death it so you know just the word peers in chapter twenty nine where in a case in nine hundred
eighty nine.
An Aboriginal man in Queensland say well I want to a jury of my Aboriginal peers you want an Aboriginal jury.
And justice. MacPherson is a very distinguished judge from Queens and also a noted writer on legal history.
Point they have the word Piers has to mean and straight in context fellow citizens.
So one way of making Medicare to work in the modern context is reinterpret the language to fit their present situation.
It's also seen as a value in the legal system. And what are these values Well here's three of them.
And it's not an exhaustive list and I was of mentioned some of these other values that is if it is banned by the law.
The King of course made the promises and twelve fifteen.
Other of course he was to gain has been broken connivance with the pope
and kings for many centuries thereafter took the view that parts of the law particularly what was called the
corroborative cannot be questioned in any court. And it was much.
Later we get the idea should be bound by law and not just as a doctrine
but for the effective operation of key institutional arrangements such as judicial review.
Which again didn't exist in the thirteenth century.
Secondly and this is wonderful that says have a general right to liberty. So his wonderful new self well story.
And I did twenty seven there was a wedding and the wedding saying there is a choice of songs produced of Roy it
and the bride and groom had to drag the poor man free and they arrested the two attackers
and brought me for a magistrate who after pronouncing on the aesthetic and moral values of the lyrics.
Went on to say that made in the car to give every Englishman the right to sing.
Now there's nothing there's nothing in there in the Kadare about singing.
Although as I mentioned earlier there's a widespread belief that made the Carter was signed and one schoolboy hell
or not you know five in Australia one bright LED right. The king had to sing Magna Carta. So it's kind of a double era.
Now obviously when we're talking about the right to sing will come a long way from Runnymede.
We're no longer talking about particular medieval grievances but a general right to liberty.
And also the right to self-government because Magna Carta was frequently invoked in eight hundred forty S.
Including the legislative council of New South Wales.
Who produced a demand for self-government in which they argued amongst other things that.
People in New South Wales had been did not write the rights given and make an account of one of these rights
and invention clearly was the idea that Magna Carta gets a right to representative government which is nonsense.
But nonsense has value and he. Stry. Mess aren't just there to be refuted we can do that easily.
But they also are often the basis from which arguments are constructed even thief think they're wrong headed.
But then those are subsequent arguments take off and take hold
and there's a century in why view of what's happened here.
Has also been used in political argument not just legal arguments for instance there was a large debate in late
twenty's and thirty's in New South Wales. Asked for civilian juries.
And it was argued that this was something that been guaranteed by making a counter
and this was the obvious effect that this was used to invoke this way tell you tells you what a pair of iconic river
sainted and was part of course of the intellectual inheritance of the people who came here.
It's also been used to criticize government measures designed his earliest.
Later this year in the Senate centerline home when discussing
and terrorism was thought that there was laws being proposed or an affront to the counter. So this argument has some.
Ability to survive in a straight. So it still matters.
It shows the adaptability of the legal order and that's one of their enormous strengths.
And it's one of the features of common law systems of course we actually live in the age of statutes.
But they're also adaptable and she no. But many acts of parliament are actually revisions amendments changes.
We don't live in a static system.
It's part of what the later tradition of liberty under the law should we all enjoy in Australia.
I think it's an essential part of civic knowledge and it is a matter for a great.
And obviously Chawner of us who are in the history professional know more about this than I do that the teaching of
constitutional history which used to be virtually all of history. Once it's now been set aside and taken over by.
Other areas of history are not complaining about that in the sense that these other areas famous history in history
social history should be taught. They're part of the story. But there is a loss as well as again.
And we have lost something. I think. And lastly the rule of law. Well we know the elements of the rule of law.
Some of these have been mentioned it's a complex thing of course it's not just institutions and doctrines.
It's also other things such as the sociology of a society. I'm always moved when I go to vote. Why.
Even though the person I'm voting for won't win. Or my not all the party may not.
I am moved because it's incredibly civilised peaceful way of deciding a key question who should govern.
And we know the alternatives.
We don't have the Army called up to protect us from goons we don't have ballot stuffing we don't have rigging we have
the occasional screw up that have friends as they did in Western Australia but that's a really rare thing
and it's worth remembering a stranger is a world leader in election administration.
And we've been doing it very well for a very long time
and it's not an accident that this train a little commission for instance has taken itself abroad frequently to advise
other places on how to run things in fifty manner. So we this.
All of this of course means that we live in a free society.
If you look at all the net international indicators such as Freedom House which I should tell it was set up by Eleanor
Roosevelt nine hundred forty three.
It's a website and you can they write countries by their level of freedom democracy. And astride of course.
Naturally is regarded as a free country. So I think the enormous achievement.
To finish of Major Carter was it's adaptability. And the fact that subsequent generations.
Enclosing aero Narromine way.
Have actually reinforced it developed it expanded changed it to produce the system we have today
and that I think is the true achievement of Magna Carta not what the king did or thought he did in twelve fifteen.
But what it's actually now to come. THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH for that.
David
and I personally am pleased that you mentioned the importance of constitutional history it is a very important part of
history said far as I'm concerned that we do have time for questions.
To cut the cost problem of colonialism and British colonial colonialism in particular.
Is the contradiction between the rhetorical at home and bear the wonderful freedoms of the English.
I mean when when Blackstone writes his commentaries he talks about the most perfect constitution
and the fact that they took some of those institutions but not all of them when they settled abroad.
And
when I saw it abroad of course I didn't bring the entire system with them because in a colonial system before representative
government. He had Crown Colony government.
You didn't have representative power mints the result of a no legislature was wholly appointed these sorts of things.
So this is actually meant that the settlers often brought the English ideas with them
but they didn't always find them fully developed here because the institutional arrangements would rather different.
And this is what was used to make the Carter.
And I didn't actually mention the sun where you've asked a question why three in my. Subtitle.
Because I think No three.
Jeremy Bentham who never came to Australia wrote a piece on the system of justice in New South Wales.
And which one of his principal complaints was that the people of New South Wales have been denied Magna Carta in this
expanded sense and which I've been using. So this is this is one why.
In a sense the English undermined their own colonial system because they brought some of these values with them which
were then used by these people move heard from John to have was used in various instance in Australia to attack the
colonial system for not being fully British where given the full range of British liberties.
YES RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT.
Yes yes there was and of course the American lesson was a great lesson and from which we benefited.
Because by that although there was of course a near disaster in two incidents
and light eight hundred thirty six Canada. As well.
And so by the eight hundred forty eight hundred forty specifically Canada.
Representative government and responsible government that nearly promised two years later
when people asked for the same arrangement.
So once the genie is out of the bottle once it started to grant more autonomy and more self-government.
But obviously all the different parts of the Empire want it
and obviously the ones who got it quickly were the ones who see that most British.
But there's also in other contradictions in the system as it was an English statute not Scottish.
So in New Zealand which is where our version from there's a contradiction between the Scots wanted which is a
Presbyterian rule in parts of the country with the Church of Scotland
and the Britishness So after a while Englishness becomes Britishness.
And this and this of course is an aside insult to the Scots who think well
when it was maybe we should think about the original division.
But yes it is a contradiction between the a veiled objectors at home.
But it would also the other thing I want to stress is that there's a tendency to pose we've got all in my new situation
mainland or Britain. Actually we fade back into the system and I've written about rebelling. So.
The British didn't have a secret ballot.
We got we in for me the first
and they got the idea from us because they had an inquiry in London they brought over a Victorian service try
and witnesses. And when they brought in their own ballot law. It was modeled on the laws in Australia.
And there's a lot of other innovations that were made in Australia we had a step Bush church they did the first quickly
one last point religious toleration the University of Sydney engine eight hundred fifty says that we no religious test
for entry to the university.
And all the other university statutes since in the Strait of a doctor that that's important because the god awful kind
which up to eight hundred seventy two you had to subscribe to the Articles of Faith.
The Church of England they had a religious test. We never did.
Well I mentioned I had a look at some of the history textbooks which have very brief passages is taught. Badly.
Is part of what I call the source and castles approach to medieval history lesson the time them.
How with some costumes and other things. Now it's fairly pointed out that this is often taught at the age of thirteen.
And the abstract ideas might be difficult for students of that age to grasp how the earlier generations weren't.
So limited and seem to be able to get a hold of it unless you're writing about singing rather than signing
and why for those things were wrong. Anyway.
And of course some of the other hell is where Larry is that we were not made the Carter said the King couldn't put
anyone in a lady's house without her permission.
At the album phrase just seized a property means be deprived of property. So one student right.
A person can be diseased without their own consent.
You can find all this stuff by putting the phrase Go boy hello so I have all this in that wonderful national newspaper
database. It's great. One more it's got nothing to make because you got to hear it.
What's a word for a man who has only ONE WIFE Well we know the answers but to me. Monogamy.
The answer given monotony sure the turn is.
The turn does but the constant demand is called as we now use it is only the form of the.
Rich where you see a person who's been detained.
Once to get themselves before a court and asked the court to determine like Galatea of a detention that had sub D.C.
End and form of the writ really I need develops from the fifteen eighties on.
And takes off from that sixteen seventeen a famous case involving William Penn of Pennsylvania.
Who had an illegal meeting and was tried and the recorder of London ordered the jury to come in with a certain verdict.
He actually deprived them of food meat drink
and tobacco because it arrived from Virginia earlier in the century until they comply with his wishes
and of the nature of this case is a very famous one namely the judge can't bully jury into a verdict against their
wishes.
And that's another example of the thing we've just pointed out your brilliant book written in nine hundred ten who from
England to empires throughout the history of habeas corpus which is a writ of Liberty.
Which was part of all these legal systems so you got written liberty in places where there are often a lot of illegal
detentions or even lawful detentions which within the subject of criticism. Well.
They like us have attributed a lot of their values to it in this book I help. I contribute last year.
There's essays by American scholars on Magna Carta and the Supreme Court.
And scream referred to one hundred sixty times or something in U.S. Supreme Court decisions.
And incidentally referred to new written dozens of times in the parliamentary debates I think from one thousand nine
hundred on.
So all this stuff
and this is where I would do this work quickly because a one does a digitalization it's given us a lot of material.